i would like to introduce kirsty who is
going to talk
uh in much detail about safe's notes
equity and the like kirsty
all right good morning everybody so
my name is kirsty nathu i'm the cfo one
of the partners here at y combinator
um and i have now worked with probably
over 1500 companies in terms of getting
them
incorporated doing our yc investment
and then seeing them through their their
subsequent raises
either on convertible instruments or on
equity rounds
so i've seen kind of a lot by now um
and so this this presentation is is to
give you
some understanding of some of the things
that people don't necessarily understand
when they're raising money
um and to hopefully help you avoid some
of the pitfalls
that we've seen with that some of the
mistakes that we've seen founders make
so the key the key message in all of
this presentation
is that it's important that you
understand at all stages of the
company's life cycle
how much of the company you've sold to
investors and
in connection with that how much
therefore you also own
and the thing the thing that makes this
complicated is that most companies will
raise money on convertible instruments
first
and because those convertible
instruments aren't yet shares
it's not immediately obvious for a lot
of founders how much of the company
they've sold
so i'm going to talk through some of the
mechanics of that
and help you understand how how all that
works so that you don't get surprised
when it's too late and you can't do
anything about it
so the other thing that you should also
be aware of is that
a lot of companies and a lot of founders
will just say oh i don't need to worry
about my cap table
my lawyers deal with my cap table i
don't need to worry and actually
that's a really dangerous statement um
again you should make sure that you're
understanding this it's your
responsibility as the ceo or as the
founder of the company to to understand
all of this
and there's lots of ways that you can
maintain your cap table
there's lots of ways that you can you
can keep track of this
and the simplest form is just a
spreadsheet all it's going to show is
who owns how many shares
and that's it that's all you need at the
beginning but there are other services
out there that can help um and i'll i'll
include them on a list of resources
after the presentation but there's tools
like
cap table dot io and carter which also
help
for you to keep track of these things
okay so these are the these are the
three sections that i'm going to talk
about first of all i'm going to talk
about safes
and particularly for us companies
most companies will raise money first on
safes or some other convertibles
convertible instruments which i will
talk about briefly as well
and i know jeff mentioned the safe last
week um
in a little bit of detail but i'm going
to go into much more detail on that
and also how how the sections of the
safe works
the s stands for simple and so hopefully
you will you will believe me with that
and you will all be
ready to understand what's going on in
that safe
as you come out of this presentation
then we'll talk some more about dilution
again so you can see we're going to walk
through the life cycle of a company
from incorporation up to raising a
priced series a round so you can see how
how things change over that period and
then i'll give you some top tips
on other other items to do with raising
money
all right so first of all the safe so
let's cover what it is
and then we'll go through the details of
of how a safe
is built up so as i said safe
the s stands for simple the rest of it
is a simple agreement
for future equity and put simply it's
a instrument where the investor will
give you money now
in exchange for a promise from the
company to give shares to the investor
at a future date when you raise money on
a priced round
there are minimal negotiations with a
safe really there's only
two things that you're probably going to
negotiate with the investor
which is how much money you're going to
how much money the investor will
put into the company and what valuation
cap
so really those two things are the
things to negotiate
whereas when you compare that with a
priced round there's a whole raft of
things to negotiate
and that's what makes a priced round a
lot harder to
to close and to raise money on than than
a safe does
so so that's why often companies will
start with a safe and then when they
get to the point of being able to raise
more money and they have a lead investor
which they negotiate with for the price
round
then the safes when they convert into
shares will piggyback on
the terms that has been negotiated with
the lead investor
in the priced round
the other thing to bear in mind is that
a safe is not debt
so some of you will have raised on
what's known as convertible debt
that's a different instrument um debt
has generally an interest rate attached
to it and it has a maturity date
where the debt needs to be repaid safes
have neither of those things
so it's important to understand that
there is a distinction between the two
instruments but in terms of conversion
in in the way that they convert in a
priced round there are some similarities
so this is the first section in the safe
and this paragraph actually includes
pretty much all the key details
that you need to understand in a safe
so it talks about
in exchange for payment by investor
you're gonna
the investor is putting in a certain
amount of dollars
around this date and
down here the valuation cap is some
number
so really those two blanks are the two
negotiating points
this paragraph here is something that
we've added just recently
in our newest version of safes and this
is something that will hopefully help
you
so that once you've read our safe that
we have available on our website once
if there's this paragraph on the safe
then you know that
you have read the safe the idea behind
this is that if anything changes in the
safe they can't
you either the company or the investor
cannot say this paragraph it can't say
that it's the same as the safe that's on
the y combinator website
and so you'll know as a founder that you
should be looking at it more closely to
see what's been changed
so this is just something to keep your
eyes open for when you
when you if you receive a safe from an
investor
okay so the anatomy of the safe is
pretty straightforward it's only five
pages in length
so it's not very long we've tried really
hard to keep the language
not too legal and so it's easy to
understand
and really it's split into is split into
five sections
section one talks about what happens in
a various
um different sets of events and so
most of the time what's going to happen
is there will be an equity financing
at some point in the future and so the
first part of the section talks about
what happens then how does the safe
convert
or there might be a liquidity event
either company might get sold
before the safe converts so it also
addresses what happens
if the company is sold before the say
whilst the safe is still outstanding
or the company might decide to close
down whilst the safe's still outstanding
so it also addresses that
so those are the three real key events
that might
drive change um from the safe so it
addresses all of those and often we get
questions from founders or from
investors saying but what happens
what happens if and actually these three
sections are the answers to pretty much
all of those questions
and then there's a couple of other
sections where we clarify the
liquidation priority
which just means who comes first in the
queue to be repaid
in these different situations um
and also clarifying that the safe
actually terminates i.e it does no
longer exist
if any of the top three events happen
so that section is kind of your
instruction booklet
if something happens in your company
that's the section you look at to see
what happens to you safe
then the next section section two is
just the definitions section
so anything that we refer to within the
safe will be explained in section two so
if you're not sure
what the company capitalization
definition is you go to section two to
look at that for a for an explanation
section three are the representations
that the company makes to the investor
so it's it's saying things like the
company um
the company is duly formed it's it's
correctly formed in delaware um
section four is the representations that
the investors make to the company so
it's things like the investor saying
yes i agree i'm um i'm an accredited
investor
um and then section five is kind of
legal boilerplate language
that that needs to be in there
so really from your point of view the
sections that you really need to
understand are sections one
and sections two obviously you need to
know what you're representing
in section three as well but those
section one and section two are the key
key parts
and that bit is only three pages long of
the safe
so i'm pretty sure you can all read
three pages
and understand what's going on so i
encourage you to do that okay some of
you may have heard
um in the last couple of weeks we
announced to move
to a different type of safe um
we've really we've introduced the
concept of post money safes
and it's important that we
understand what post money means what it
basically means
is after all the safes have converted
what happens
at that point and we'll go into that in
a little bit more detail
in a moment but it's it's easy to get
confused about what post money means
here but it's after all the safes
um and the reason why we introduced
these is that we
we wanted to make it easier for founders
to understand
the dilution that they were taking i.e
how much of the company they'd sold to
investors and so
how much less of the company they owned
it was all it's a lot easier to to
understand that with post money safes
than with the previous safes that we had
which were known as pre-money safes
okay so basically when we're talking
about pre-money and post money
we're talking about the same thing it's
just a different way to
express it to explain it and so
in both the priced round and for safes
the formula stays the same so the
pre-money valuation
plus the amount of money raised equals
the post money valuation
of the company okay so if you have
a five million dollar pre-money
valuation
and you raise a million dollars then the
post money valuation of the company
is six million dollars okay
and that's important to remember in a
moment
but really that's that's as simple as it
gets
so then based on that so that you can
understand
how much of the company you've sold when
you're raising money
um on safes the formula is just
your owners or the ownership of the
investors the ownership that the the
investors will take
is their amount raised divided by the
post money
either valuation in the case of a priced
round or valuation cap
in the case of a safe
so in our example before if the
investors were putting in one million
dollars
and the post money valuation was six
million dollars
then they will own sixteen point six
seven percent
of the company does that all make sense
to everybody so far
okay good so i'm going to i'm going to
talk
only about safes with valuation caps
here to keep things simple but just be
aware that there are
other different flavors of safes that
you can use and that you may have
already used um
or that you may find that you you use in
future so there may be the concept
of a discount instead of a cap um so
instead of capping the valuation at say
six million dollars
it says um there's a there's a 20
discount
on the series a price
there's also an uncapped safe which
basically just says i'm going to put
money in now as an investor and when you
do a priced round
i'll get the same price as the priced
round
investors are going to get that's pretty
uncommon because the investors who are
putting in money
early want some kind of bonus for
putting in the money early
um so so it's pretty unlikely that
you'll you'll use one of those
and then finally there's a safe that's
uncapped with a
most favored nation clause which
basically what that says
is i'm not going to agree
a cap right now but if you raise some
money from some other investors who do
have a cap
and that those terms are better than my
terms i get their terms
as well as an investor so this one can
sometimes happen if you're raising money
very early on
and you don't really know what the cap
is and maybe you know you just want to
punt it for another month or two
um but it just creates a little bit more
admin for the founders because it's
another thing that they have to
keep track of um so we we see them
sometimes again not all that common
um by far the most common is just the
valuation cap
only all right so now
we understand safes and how they're made
up we're going to talk about dilution
and understanding how your cap tables
work
all right so we're going to we're going
to walk through this process so we're
going to start with our company hitting
corporation
which uh carolyn talked about right at
the start of the startup school course i
believe so hopefully
this will not be anything new to you
then we're going to talk about what
happens when you raise
on some raise money on safes on post
money saves
then we're going to talk about what
happens as you hire people
and start to issue equity to employees
and then the company is going to do a
priced round
and so what happens to the cap table at
that point
and now i'll warn you this is starting
to get into the math section
of the whole thing so turn your brains
on and keep concentrating
all right so incorporation so let's just
assume it's a really simple company
there's two founders and they split
their shares
equally between the two of them so in
this example
each founder owns 4.625 million
shares so there's a total of
9.25 million shares issued and each
founder owns 50
that's pretty straightforward right and
so at this point
in order in order for them to own those
shares
the founders have done the paperwork
they've granted those shares
through a restricted stock purchase
agreement and there's vesting on those
shares
as was talked about with with carolyn
earlier in the
um earlier in the the course
okay so then the next thing that's going
to happen is this company
raises some money on a post-money safe
and they raise from two
investors so the first investor comes in
quite early
and they put in two hundred thousand
dollars at
a four million dollar post-money
valuation cap and then a little bit
later on
investor b comes in puts in 800 000
at an 8 million dollar post money
valuation cap
so if you remember back to our formulas
the ownership that investor a has at
this point
is their amount of money that they've
put in divided by the post money
valuation cap
which gives them five percent of the
company
same for investor b 800 000 over 8
million which gives them 10 percent of
the company
so in total the founders at this stage
have sold
15 of the company so even though
this doesn't change the actual cap table
because these aren't shares at this
point this is just a safe this is just a
promise to give shares in future
the founders should know at this stage
that they have sold 15 percent of the
company
and if they've sold 15 of the company
then they can no longer own
a hundred percent of the company so now
instead of the founders owning a hundred
percent of the company between them
they've been diluted by the fifteen
percent so they're going down
to eighty-five percent of the company
so it's important to have that in your
brain when you're raising money
because whilst the cap table like i say
doesn't change
the fact that you've just sold 15
percent of the company
is an important fact and it's an
important thing to know
because you want to make sure that
you're not selling too much of the
company
because you know that there's a lot of
future fundraisings that are going to
happen with the company
and therefore there's going to be more
future dilution
is everyone happy with how we've got to
that fifteen percent
yes the question so the founders are
only ones getting diluted at this point
uh the earlier investor doesn't get
value right so the question is
it's only the founders that are being
diluted at the moment and yes that's
that's exactly right
because that's the construct of the post
money safes the
the all the later the later safe
investors don't dilute the earlier safe
investors
it just dilutes the existing
shareholders and at this stage it's just
the founders who are the existing
shareholders
does it make sense to have shares in the
treasury
so that they can cover the anticipated
dilution
okay so the question is does it make
sense to have shares
authorized but unissued i think is what
you mean
so at this stage it doesn't necessarily
make a difference as you'll see in a
moment
you actually create new shares that
you're going to issue to these these
safeholders when they convert
um so at this stage it's it's fine to
just have the shares that
the founders have and maybe some that
you want to give out for hiring
why investment d has different uh post
money valuation cap well in this example
so the question is why do they have
different post money valuation caps and
so in this example
um you know it could it could be for
very any number of reasons but in this
example we're assuming that you know
this
this one happened maybe a month after
incorporation and maybe this one
happened six months after incorporation
and more as more has gone on in the
company and so
slightly less risk and so the company
has been able to negotiate a different
cap
but things things change through the
company and it's totally fine to have
different caps because as you can see
from here
you just you just calculate everything
separately
and then add it all together okay so
companies raised a million dollars
first thing it's probably going to do
with that money is hire some people
and when you hire employees you're
probably going to give them some equity
and so in this example the company
creates at this stage
a option pool otherwise known as an esop
or an employee incentive plan there's
lots of different names for it
um and in this example they have created
a plan or a pool that has 750 000
shares in it and they've issued out of
their
650 000 shares to
early employees so this has now changed
their cap table
because they've issued shares and so the
fact that there's
there's more shares um being being
issued means that the cap table changes
because we now have more
shareholders and so now we have
a total of 10 million shares that have
been
um fully diluted basically means the
combination of issued
and set aside in the options pool
in this case so now we have our founders
instead of owning a hundred percent
have 92.5 percent of the company
and the option plan in total is seven
and a half percent
of the company but remember
those safes so these founders don't
actually have 92.5
because they have also sold 15 of the
company
and so actually they own less than the
92 and a half percent
um they've actually they actually own 85
percent
of that which is about 78.6
so again this is where it gets dangerous
for the founders
if they forget about the safes the
founders are sitting there saying well i
own 92.5
this is great i own still loads of the
company and they
have forgotten about the safes and the
dilution they're about to take from that
so again it's really important to keep
track of how much you've sold
on your safes so that you can
do that calculation and say actually i
don't have 92.5
i have 85 of that because i've sold 15
of the company but it's also
these numbers have been diluted by those
safes as well
so as you'll see in a moment these
numbers change as well
okay so now we're going to fast forward
about let's say a year
um the company is doing well
it's raised a price round and it has a
term sheet for the price round which
says that the
pre-money valuation of the round is 15
million dollars
and they're going to raise a total of 5
million
of which the lead investor which is the
investor that they
do all of the negotiations with is going
to invest four million dollars
and so if you remember from our formula
at the start
the post-money valuation is the
pre-money valuation plus the total raise
so the post-money valuation is 20
million
the other thing that gets negotiated as
part of the price round
is the option pull increase
so generally what happens is that the
investors in the series a will say okay
we're going to put some money in
we know that this money is going to go
towards hiring so we want you to create
an option pool for all the new employees
that you're going to
employ and give equity to in advance
so that it's sitting there ready for
those employees and so
usually you see that the um the option
pool is about 10 percent
it might go up to about 15 but anything
more than that is
is fairly non-standard
yes where did that come from over there
okay yes
so you so the question is is the 10
coming from founders or collectively and
you'll see in a moment is going to
dilute the existing shareholders
and the safeholders but it doesn't
dilute the new money
so how is that option tool represented
on the capital
is
so the question is how is the option
pool represented on the cap table so
if we go back to here we just show it so
that we have
the options available from the pool that
haven't been issued
is a line and anything that has been
issued from the pool is a separate line
the reason why we show those two things
separately is that these
these shares are considered outstanding
they're considered issued
whereas these aren't and so that's the
difference between what
that's what fully diluted means it means
outstanding shares which are these two
lines
plus any shares reserved under the
option pool
all right where are we oh so so
quick quick maths question for for you
what do we expect that the um
lead investor will own what percentage
of the company do we think the lead
investor is going to own
after the round closes
20 yeah for the lead investor 25
in total for all of the series a
investors
okay because they're the lead investor
is going to put in 4 million
divided by 20 million dollars gives 20
so you'll see in a minute the cap table
that that all works through in the
calculations but it's always good to
just do that quick
check so that you can sense check what's
going on in your cap table
all right so in a priced round where you
have
or where the company has raised money
just on post money saves
and then has raised a priced round three
things will happen
and these three things happen at the
same time in terms of the documents
but in terms of the calculations it's
important that the
order is correct and so the three things
with post money safes
is that the first thing that happens is
the safes convert into shares
then an options pool is increased or
created if there isn't one already
and then the new investors invest and
you'll see in a minute how that all
works through
with the calculations
now one other thing that starts to get a
little bit confusing here
is one of the the sort of the lingo of
how this works is that often
the the lawyers and the the founders
will talk about the
safes being included in the pre-money
and what that's basically saying
is that when the new investors invest
and they calculate their price per share
the calculation includes the shares
from the conversion of the safes so even
though the safes themselves
are referred to as post money safes
that's talking about how the safes
convert
this sentence where the safes are
included in the pre-money
is talking about how the series a price
is calculated
so it gets a little bit confusing
because it's talking about post money
and pre-money
but that's just something to bear in
mind when when this happens and
obviously at the time that you're
raising a priced round you're going to
have a lot of advisors you're going to
be working with lawyers who can explain
all of this to you as well
all right let's go through these three
steps then
so the first step is our safes are going
to convert
and we already know because we've
already done the calculation
that these safes are going to convert
into 15
of the company and so 15 of the company
means 15 of the total fully diluted
shares
both common shares and preferred shares
so investors get preferred shares which
have
a different set of rights and privileges
than
the common shares which is what the
founders and employees
get so we have enough information here
in the cap table
that we have here to calculate what the
actual number of shares are here
because we know that they're going to be
15 of the total issued shares
so we know that this is 85
of the total issued shares so we know
what our total is
and then once we get the totals we can
work out what five percent of that
is and what ten percent of that is so
after a bit of algebra these are the
numbers that come
through so now at this point we have
11 million 764 705 shares
in total because it's preferred shares
plus common shares
our first safe investor who we said was
going to have five percent
has 588 000 shares which represents 5
percent of that 11.7 million
and our second safe investor has 10
percent
now it's important to remember that this
is part way
through a whole process it's part way
through those three steps
that are happening in a priced round and
so actually you're never going to see
your cap table
looking like this this is this is just
one step in the calculation but it's
just to break out so that you can see
where that 15 percent
has come from and you can also see here
that when we were saying that the
founders instead of owning
um 92.5 they owned about 78
you can see that here because they've
been diluted by that 15
as have the um employees with their
options
so this is this is the post money part
of the post money safes
after the safes have converted but
before
anything else has happened in relation
to the priced round
got it okay
all right so the next step is oh we
gotta have a question
okay uh so the percentage of uh if you
can't go back
so the the five percent ten percent that
has nothing to do with the
whole situation and they said they
straight
okay so the question is it doesn't does
the five and ten percent have any
any um
yeah okay so yeah so the five and ten
percent is based on the valuation cap
in the safe and so assuming the priced
round
valuation is higher than the valuation
cap in the safe
then it this is just looked at with
reference to the safe
and it's just connected to the the
existing
um shareholders if
in the very rare circumstances that the
price round is lower
than the valuation cap on the safe then
actually these safe investors will get
a better deal because they will sell
their shirt their
their safes will convert at the same
price
that the series a investors have um
which is a lower price than the
valuation cap so actually there is the
potential that this can go
up um this percentage can be higher if
the price round
is valued at a lower price
than the cap on the safe
that doesn't trigger the conversion
it still triggers the conversion even if
the valuation is lower because it's the
fact that they've raised money that
triggers the
conversion not the price so it's just
something to bear in mind that
when we're talking about this that post
money saves and in this example that
you're you're selling 15
of the company there is potential that
it could be higher
but it's a pretty rare situation where
you raise a priced round that's priced
lower
than the the valuation of your safes
and it's also something to bear in mind
of trying not to negotiate too hard on
the safes to make your your caps too
high
because if you raise money on 100
million dollar cap but then you can only
raise money on
a 25 million dollar priced round let's
say
then you're actually selling more of the
company to those safeholders than you
expected
okay so the question is if there's
convertible debt so this would this
would happen here
as well so it would that the calculation
for convertible debt is
is slightly different um but it would
happen
in here and you would show them just as
other investors because they would be
converting into shares
in relation to the price round as well
what if you went crazy and actually gave
or sold 85 percent of your company and
the valuation is lower at the end what
happens
you can't share with them well so that's
that's the
the big question so the question is what
happens if you go crazy and sell 85
of your company that yeah i mean that's
that's the problem
um that founders can can raise too much
money
on too low valuation caps when they're
raising on convertible
instruments they don't realize how much
dilution they're taking
and then they get to their priced rounds
and they look at their cap table and
they're just like
what i only own you know 10 of the
company now
and unfortunately there's not a huge
amount you can do at that point because
you've already
entered into the contracts with the
investors to to do this
and so that's why it's important to not
get into that situation in the first
place
that the saves are price
of the cap is higher than the price
range then
it would lose actually a lot more can
you explain that because i thought the
uh
it would uh although the price of the
gap was actually the cap right because
so yeah so the question is how to how
the cap works in terms of
in relation to the priced rounds so if
the if the price round
is higher than the cap then the safe
converts at the cap
which means that the safeholders
basically get more shares for the same
amount of money
than the series a investors get so
that's in that situation that's how you
know
what percentage you're selling but in
the situation where the cap
is higher than the priced round
then you would never
it it wouldn't be fair to the
safeholders to have them getting a worse
deal
than the series a investors because they
put money in earlier
and so what happens then is that you the
the calculation
if you remember if you go back to the
section one of the safe where it says
what happens in a
price equity round situation it says
if the if the cap is
um if the cap is higher than the price
round
then they just use the priced round
price to calculate their shares
and so because that priced round price
is different
these numbers will go up
well it depends it depends on the delta
so if it's if it's only a little bit
different then yeah maybe instead of 15
they've sold 16 let's say but if it's if
the delta is really big then it could go
up
but again it's it's something to be
aware of it's
in the current environment it's pretty
unlikely that
um people raise price rounds at
lower valuations than their safes just
because when you're raising money on
safes
the investors won't agree to invest at a
ridiculously high valuation
because they want they want to get that
bonus of the lower price
when they say when their saves convert
yeah okay let's keep going
all right so this this step you're going
to have to trust me on
um so the next step in the in the
section
is that the option pool is increased
and this is actually quite a complicated
calculation it gets a little bit
circular
and i'm going to be sharing a model with
everybody so you can see how this works
if you're interested
but basically what you're trying to do
is to get to 10
of um the post-money shares are sitting
available in the option pool and in this
example we're going to increase
our option pool by 1.695 million
and you'll see in a minute that that
flows through into the cap table and
you'll see that 10
but just trust me on this one because
this is this is quite a complicated
calculation
and then step three the new money
invests so this is where we have our
series a investors putting in five
million dollars
and there is a couple of calculations
that happen
in there um so the price per share
that's calculated for the round is the
valuation
divided by the capital capitalization so
this is the pre-money valuation
15 million and when we're talking about
capitalization here
what we are meaning is this is the total
fully diluted shares
after the safe conversion and the option
pool increase
so that's why this is step three because
our sha our safes have converted
and our option pool has increased and so
we have
our 10 million shares that we'd issued
9.25 to the founders
725 000 in the options pool
um plus the safe conversion shares plus
the increase in the options pool
and you'll see the numbers in a moment
so then the number of shares that the
series a investors get
is the amount they're investing divided
by their price per share
so those are the three calculations that
you need to remember for your
series a
so here we go here's here here are those
calculations so we're saying that the
capitalization
we have our 10 million shares that were
already issued
we have our 1.76 million shares from the
conversion of the safes
and we have our increase to the option
pool of 1.695 million
so that gives us 13.5 million total
shares
we divide our 15 million dollars by
those shares
to get a new money price so this is the
price that the investors will pay for
their shares
of 1.114
so that means that the 5 million dollars
of new money
that's coming in will buy 4.48 million
shares and the lead investor because
they're putting in 4 million
will get 3.59 million of those shares
so these are the calculations that get
that get worked through
this is what the cap table then looks
like
post money so this is now everything's
been done in the round
so we've still got our founders we've
still got our options
those numbers haven't changed this
number's changed because it's increased
by 1.695 million
and you can see here that now this is
ten percent of the total shares which is
what we were targeting
because that was agreed in the term
sheet
we have our safe investors who the
number of shares haven't changed
because they already we'd already done
their calculation for the conversion
but their percentages have changed it's
gone down a little bit
and the reason why those have gone down
is because the safe investors have been
diluted
by the series a money and by the
increase in the options pool
and then we have our lead investor and
our other investors
in our series a and as you remember when
we did the
the quick back of envelope calculation
at the point of getting the term sheet
our lead investor owns twenty percent
our other investors own
five percent so in total they have 25
and so the founders up here now own 51.5
which is a big jump from the cap table
that they
originally were looking at where they
owned uh 92.5
and that's where this gets complicated
if you don't understand your dilution
you don't understand how much of the
company that you've sold
when you get to this point and you look
at the cap table
and you're saying oh no i only own 30 of
the company how did that happen
there isn't a lot you can do because
most of that dilution has already
happened
because you've raised money from the
safes the because you raise money on
safes
and so that's why it's super important
that you
keep track of this dilution because at
this point there isn't a lot you can do
about it
all right moving on
so a couple of couple of top tips for
you
we've mentioned briefly about
convertible notes and that's just
another instrument that you can use to
raise money in the early days
um often we find companies outside of
the us will raise money on convertible
debt
there's nothing wrong with it um
it is a little bit more complex just
because you have to deal with
interest that accrues on it and maturity
dates but
companies companies deal with that but
what i would say is try not to have a
combination
of safes and convertible notes just
because it makes things a little bit
more complicated in the calculations
so if you start raising on debt then
probably stick with it
but ideally start with safes because
it's actually making your life a little
bit easier
so again we are now
recommending that companies use
post-money saves but there are pre-money
saves available and some of you may have
already raised on pre-money saves
that's totally fine um it just makes it
a little bit more complicated to
understand dilution
but you can still do the same back of
envelope calculation to get a ballpark
figure even though it's not exactly
accurate
if you have raised money on pre-money
safes then it's fine to come
to in future raise money on post money
safes
the calculations just get a little bit
complex but it's it's totally doable so
that's fine don't panic
um would suggest that you probably move
on to post money safes
um even if you've raised money on
pre-money saves just so you can keep
track of your future dilution
and a quick word on optimization in all
of this
when you're raising money on safes don't
try to over optimize for the cap
it gets really easy to start seeing this
as a as a
um a competition and you start talking
to your friends and you start saying
well i've raised money on a six million
dollar cap and they say well i've got an
eight million dollar cap and so i'm more
successful than you are
and you know as jeff mentioned last week
fundraising is not
the be-all and end-all it's a means to
an end so
just don't don't try to over-optimize
don't try to push this
up too far because you're negotiating
with investors who do this all day and
every day
and you're probably not somebody who
negotiates this all day and every day
and actually um when i ran the numbers
on the calculation that we've just been
through if we'd have changed that 800
000 that was raised on an 8 million cap
to a 10 million cap the ownership at the
close for the founders would have been
52.7
rather than 51.5 so it's not actually a
huge difference
especially if you have two or three or
four founders co-founders
and the extra pain for negotiating that
two million dollar cap
is probably not worth it you know just
take the money
do what you need to do with the money
and make the company a success instead
okay so in conclusion use post money
safes
where you can hopefully all of you can
use those going forward
understand what you're selling with the
company so make sure that you keep track
of your dilution
and understand where where the company
is being sold
and finally again don't over optimize
for valuation caps because it doesn't
actually make as much difference as you
think it's going to make
thank you very much for listening i know
this stuff's difficult
you